Stephen Bonner Mr Speaker can I just
Begin by first condemning the recent
Spike environs and bloodshed energy
around the occupied Palestinian
territories and on behalf of his old
peer respect you're all past and in and
Israeli victims of conflict Mr Speaker
his department has acknowledged that
there is a culture of impunity when it
comes to claims committed by Israeli
settlers against Palestinians we and the
SMP wholeheartedly agree so can you tell
us exactly what the government is doing
to encourage Israel to end a widespread
and systematic discrimination against
Palestinian populations and furthermore
can you also outline any of the concrete
steps been taken to deter land seizures
to deter home demolitions and the false
evictions of Palestinian people and
their communities
uh Mr Speaker the UK enjoys a very
strong bilateral relationship with
Israel and that allows us to raise uh
issues where we disagree and we have
disagreed with settlement expansion
which uh which we have raised uh
directly and we also disagree with the
Demolition of Palestinian homes in our
position on that is long-standing and
consistent in my most recent
conversations with the Israeli foreign
minister I raised uh concerns about the
speculation of settlement building on
the E1 territories when the occupied
Palestinian territories and I'm very
pleased that there has now been a
moratorium on such expansions because to
do so I think would be damaging to the
prospects of a sustainable two-state
solution hello days
Mr Speaker in February I visited Mustafa
yata in the South Hebron Hills where the
Israeli government is planning to evict
over 1 000 Palestinians from their homes
this sits alongside president
netanyahu's election pledge to Annex
West Bank settlements amounting to 30 of
the territory while Finance Minister
smotrich recently said the village of
humara should be wiped out can I ask the
foreign secretary whether he has raised
these matters with his Israeli
counterpart and how does he intend to
ensure that the new Israeli government
abides by its obligations under
international law
uh we do raise the issues of settlement
expansion uh with the government of
Israel uh and indeed we have raised uh I
have raised with my Israeli counterpart
the need for a careful use of language
and and and a raise with both my
Palestinian and Israeli counterparts the
need for all of us to try and find ways
of de-escalating uh the tensions at this
stage I think that that must rightly be
the priority of all of us whilst we
continue to work with the Israeli
government or making sure that we keep a
sustainable two-state solution alive
Andrew Gwen thank you five years ago the
British government became the first in
the world to endorse a concept of an
international fund for Israeli and
Palestinian peace since then however
warm words have followed but very little
action so can I ask the foreign
secretary
firstly given the desperate need for
this fund right now with the
deterioration of the situation in Israel
and Palestine uh whether the UK
government will commit again to Leading
on that fund and whether he will use the
opportunity of the G7 Summit in May to
get other International Partners lined
up too
hey
people-to-people links between Israelis
and Palestinians uh is incredibly
important and we have funded and we do
fund uh projects to build cooperation
whether it be at government's government
level the People to People level we
remain in close contact with our U.S uh
in close contact with our us
counterparts about the international
fund for peace we want to make sure it
is the most effective use of funding
allocated towards People to People we
could we will always look favorably at
projects to build greater peace and
cooperation but we do want to make sure
that anything we subscribe to or any
funding we commit is done is is
allocated to the most effective way of
bringing about that reconciliation
under McDonald's
in the West Bank Town of hawara over 400
settlers backed by Israeli soldiers
torch Palestinian homes businesses and
vehicles and killed 37 year old summer
aktesh in what senior IDF commanders
have called apogram Israel's Finance
Minister smotrich who describes himself
as a fascist homophone openly said
hawara should be wiped out Mr Speaker
such extremism has given license by a
lack of international accountability so
will the minister if he agrees with the
rule of international law commit to
banning all Goods sourced from Israeli
settlements illegally built on occupied
Palestinian land
Mr Speaker as I've said in answer to
other questions uh we have made it clear
that the language that is used with
regard to Israel and the opts need to be
de-escalatory it needs to be carefully
thought through and the inflammatory
language as we have seen is unacceptable
the behavior of those settlers is
unacceptable that's been recognized by
the Israeli authorities and we want to
make sure that those people are held
account for the actions that they have
taken we will of course uh always seek
to reinforce the viability of a future
Palestinian State as part of a
sustainable two-state solution and the
decision with regards to the decision
with regard to settlement Goods is a
long-standing one and uh and and and we
don't we don't speculate about any
changes to those positions foreign
joint commitment from the Israeli
government and the Palestinian Authority
to reduce the surge of Ireland and the
Israeli government's pledge to hold new
settlement constructions but in the very
day that this commitment was signed
president prime minister Netanyahu
tweeted contrary to tweets construction
and regulation in Judea and Samaria the
West Bank will continue according to the
original planning and construction
schedule without any changes there is
and will not be any freeze this is an
indication of further violations of
international law so will he accept that
whatever his diplomatic approach is at
the moment it simply is not working
this week of the United Kingdom
alongside a number of our International
friends and allies have a like-minded
position on this and we seek to protect
the viability of a sustainable two-state
solution we have raised with the Israeli
government
our concerns about activities that might
put that future at risk this is not
something that UK does alone this is
something we do in close coordination
with a number of our International
friends and allies and that will
continue to be our diplomatic stance on
this Tom Landry the speaker last
Thursday a Hamas terrorist shot three
Israelis in the heart of Tel Aviv just a
few streets away from the British
Embassy and shooting and bombing attacks
have rocked Israel over over a year now
and this wave appears to be intensifying
with my right Uncle friend join me in
condemning these attacks and what
meaningful steps can he take to counter
this Resurgence and terrorist activities
the UK government does of course condemn
terrorism in all its forms and for
whatever whatever criticism Palestinians
may have of the Israeli government there
is no justification for terrorist action
we always encourage dialogue we always
encourage cooperation and we always
encourage actions that will de-escalate
that will continue to be our posture
with regard to Israel and the opts Lake
Drummond
they're the only way to permanently end
the palestinian-israeli conflict is to
deliver Palestinian self-determination
and preserve Israel's Jewish and
Democratic identity is through a
peaceful two-state solution can my right
honorable friend confirm that his
Department can remains committed to
achieving that solution based on 1967
borders and the recognition of Palestine
as a state
well our position on the uh on a
sustainable two-state solution is uh
long-standing we will always encourage
Israel to take actions that support that
and we have those same conversations
with representatives of the Palestinian
Authority we encourage dialogue we
encourage negotiation we encourage
cooperation and we encourage the
escalation Rob Blackman speaker the
emergence of lions den a new terrorist
group to combat uh to go alongside Hamas
Hezbollah and many other uh Islamic
terrorist groups is clearly a threat to
Israel's security and indeed to the
Palestinians as well what assessment has
my brother friend made of lion's den and
what cooperation is he uh instituting
with both the Palestinian authorities
and with the Israeli government to
combat this new form of terrorism
my honorable friend makes uh an
important point that addressing uh
terrorism is something that we will do
in close cooperation with the government
of Israel and the Palestinian Authority
neither of whom have an incentive or a
desire to allow terrorism to flourish we
will of course continue our close
corporation with the security services
within Israel to try and ensure that
Palestinians Israelis and Brits who are
in the region are all kept safe
raise these issues the Israeli Prime
Minister Deputy Prime Minister and chief
negotiator simply stormed out of the
meeting
as they come a time when simply raising
issues isn't enough
well it's better than not raising them I
would I would suggest
other minister Fabian Hamilton thank you
Mr Speaker Mr speakers we've already
heard this morning on the 26th of
February following the appalling murder
of two Israelis a violent mob of 400
settlers attacked the Palestinian town
of awara killing one injuring hundreds
and burning buildings and cars a
far-right minister in the Israeli
government as my honorable friend has
just mentioned then called for hawara to
be wiped out
now this shocking incident is part of
the deteriorating situation in the
occupied West Bank and The Wider problem
of secular violence for which too often
no one is held to account so I asked the
foreign secretary again will the
government press the Israeli authorities
to condemn and crack down on these
shocking incidents of settler violence
there has been a condemnation of uh of
these actions from within the Israeli
system and we always make it clear that
where there is uh law breaking uh that
authorities should take action and
indeed the uh within the Israeli system
uh there has been a recognition of this
action being a legal provocative and we
therefore will continue to work with the
Israeli government and the Palestinian
Authority to find ways of de-escalating
the situation
striving for peace and striving for what
I think ultimately is in the best
interest of Palestinians and Israelis
and the region which is a peaceful
sustainable two-state solution SMP
spokesperson Drew Pantry thank you Mr
Speaker we welcomed in February the
moratorium on new construction in the
settlement areas as the foreign
secretary described earlier but as we've
also heard that it was followed by an
immediate breach of trust and a blatant
one by the Israeli Prime Minister
when he's raising issues he says it's
better to raise issues than not raise
them how does he do that and how does he
measure the success of raising those
issues because we see absolutely no
evidence of that success yeah
well I don't think it's news to anyone
in the house that the situation uh in
Israel the opts is complicated and
long-standing we are not the only
country in the world that raises these
issues and we will continue we will
continue to raise the important issues
we're able to do so because we have a
strong working relationship with both
the government of Israel and the
leadership of the Palestinian Authority
as I said I had conversations with both
uh very recently we will continue to
work at uh what I as I say I think is in
all uh people's interests which is
sustainable two-state solution we will
not we will not be fatalistic about it
we will not give up just because it's
difficult if he thinks we should walk
away from it just because it is a
long-standing challenge it's a
long-standing challenge well that's up
for him we will not abandon the Israelis
or the Palestinian people we will
continue working we will continue
working for what is a sustainable
two-state solution this twist question
two
with permission Mr Speaker I will answer
the questions two and seven together
ensuring 12 years of quality education
for all girls is a British government
priority we run bilateral education
programs in 19 countries and our girls
education ChalleNGe Program is
supporting 1.6 million girls to secure a
quality education
thank you Mr Speaker June against G7
presidency the UK introduced two Global
targets for improving access to
education for girls in low and middle
income countries by
2026. can the minister say what progress
the government is making in this area
when it expects the targets will be met
what coordinating role the UK is playing
and if he will Center the voices of
girls and young women including those
most impacted by inequality and
discrimination in delivery of the
targets
well The Honorable lady is entirely
right those two specific targets were a
major priority for the UK G7 presidency
in 2021 and prioritizing foundational
learning reading writing and Counting
well is at the heart of that and we are
on track to complete both those two
Targets by the agreed date of the G7
Western thank you Mr Speaker since the
fall of some 850 000 girls have been
prevented from attending school by the
Taliban recently pupils at St Matthews C
of E Primary School in stretford
undertook a whole school March in
solidarity with the plight of Afghan
girls denied an education they have done
all they can to raise awareness of this
important issue what more does the
minister believe that his government can
do to raise awareness of this ongoing
travesty and crucially will he agree to
bring forward a comprehensive
Afghanistan strategy that takes into
account the ongoing Crackdown on the
rights of women and girls in Afghanistan
well I congratulate the school in his
constituency for that public spirited
statement about the rights of women and
the appalling violations that are taking
place in Afghanistan the Taliban is not
a monolith in in Afghanistan there are
parts of the country where the education
is taking place both at primary and
secondary level for girls and it's a job
of the International Community to try
and persuade and argue with the Taliban
Administration that that what is
happening in those particular areas
should be extended across the whole
Country Ford
129 million girls out of school across
the world can I congratulate the my
right honorable friend and the fcdo on
putting girls education at the heart of
the women and girls strategy that was
announced last week the international
parliamentary Network for Education
brings together parliamentarians from
over 60 different countries to promote
the importance of education so will he
encourage members of this house to sign
up to this network so that we continue
to work with others to make sure that no
children's left behind and Mr Speaker
will you join
well I'm certain Mr Speaker that if you
were to sign it most colleagues will
follow your lead
um my right honorable friend has done a
great job herself on this area between
2015 and 2020 the UK supported over 8
million girls getting into school and 65
percent of those girls were living in
fragile countries
Mr speaker thank you um one of the
biggest barriers to education worldwide
is poor health in 2021 over 600 000
people worldwide died of malaria so will
the minister please commit to renew the
UK government's commitment towards
meeting the 2030 Commonwealth goal of
ending malaria and also provide maximum
support to the global fund
well as my honorable friend knows we
committed to the latest replenishment on
the global fund a sum of 1 000 million
pounds so we are right behind the
aspirations which he has expressed his
right to to say that a child dies every
minute from malaria entirely needlessly
and that is a very and dealing with that
as a top priority of the government
thank you Mr Speaker by the middle of
this Century Africa will be home to a
billion children yet in places like
Northern Nigeria half of girls are out
of school achieving Universal girls
education would end our marriage half
input mentality and drastically reduce
early childbearing so can the minister
update the house on what progress has
been made towards our G7 presidency
pledge to get 40 million more girls into
school and explain how this squares with
the government's decision to cut the
fcdo's education gender and equality
budget in half last year
well Mr Speaker we are looking at the
budgets for uh the next financial year
and indeed the year after and we will
come to the house and set out what they
are but she should be in no doubt as I
explained to her honorable friend that
this is a top priority if you want to
change the world you can do so by
educating girls it's the first foremost
way of achieving it and the government
is absolutely behind that agenda some
peace books personality thank you Mr
Speaker we'd all strongly support the
education of girls worldwide and that's
something we should all be working upon
but the danger also is that the UK
should avoid Reinventing the wheel and
the EU does already have a hundred
cooperation agreements on education
which the UK until recently was very
much part of a leading part of surely
with the thought in EU UK relations
which I commend the government for for
fixing the Northern Ireland protocol
difficulties surely There's an
opportunity for the UK to fold itself
back into these Frameworks not to
reinvent the wheel and to get more girls
into education yeah
speaker he is quite right that we take a
totally unideological approach towards
educating girls and women so we go with
what is most effective what works and if
the EU produces programs which are good
value for taxpayers money then of course
we will look at them
Nick Smith
number three please Mr Speaker
[Applause]
with permission Mr Speaker I will answer
questions three and nine together East
Africa currently represents the world's
largest and most severe humanitarian
crisis we have allocated 156 million
pounds in life-saving Aid across the
region this financial year
Nick Smith
thank you Mr Speaker uh Oxfam estimate
that one person is likely to die every
36 seconds in East Africa due to food
insecurity but yesterday's integrated
review refresh failed to acknowledge
this unfolding crisis now drought and
famine has displaced nearly 2 million
people in Ethiopia and Somalia recently
so what further action can the
government take to support people on the
ground and ensure that they can return
home safely
well I'm sure Mr Speaker that when he
has time to study the IR in detail that
was published yesterday he will see that
there is a lot to welcome in it about
the future of Britain's International
Development leadership
um in in respect of the area which he
mentions he's quite right to talk about
the intense humanitarian needs that
exist there in Ethiopia we are helping
to deliver humanitarian support to 8
million people alongside efforts to
promote water conservation in Sudan 320
000 vulnerable people are thanks to
British assistance for fooding food
support in South Sudan 200 000 are
getting emergency food and nutrition and
in Somalia where I was in December since
2018 for 0.4 million people have
received Water Sanitation and hygiene
support from Britain and 3.2 million
have received emergency food so he may
rest assured we are absolutely on the
case on this and doing everything we can
to support the international effort to
counter what may well be this year the
fifth year of drought okay
156 million pound that the minister
referred to have Aid is five times less
than provided by the UK government six
years ago for a milder crisis in a week
where we are talking about displaced
people we are facing an exodus on
biblical proportions in East Africa what
more can this government do to help
those communities stay in their homes
well he's he's absolutely right that the
whole aims of British development policy
are to help people remain in their own
homes and be safe and secure and indeed
prosperous uh there what we are seeing
in the Horn of Africa is an immense
crisis of extraordinary proportions
which the whole International Community
has to respond to not only with money
but also with skill and expertise and
British leadership is right at the front
of that
James dedridge thank you Mr Speaker much
has talked about the deaths in the
battlefield in Ukraine but what
assessment does the department made of
the impact of grain prices as a result
of the grain not coming through from
Ukraine into East Africa
um and actually it's quite possible and
I'd be interested in in testing this
decision that more people have died in
East Africa as a result of the war in
Ukraine and has actually died within the
confines of that country
well Mr Speaker I can't comment on his
last point but he's absolutely right
that as a result of Putin's illegal
brutality and invasion of uh Ukraine
there have been disruptions to Food
Supplies into particularly the Sahel but
also East Africa that is causing uh
Rising inflation it's causing food
shortages and Putin's stands condemned
for the effect of his actions in that
respect as well as every other
can I refer to my register of interests
a few weeks ago I had the privilege of
visiting Kenya and meeting students who
graphically described to me the impact
that drought caused by climate change is
having on their lives and their food
supply it's about fell crops and also
about boreholes that are drying up but
it's also impacted on their education so
what my marathon of a friend considered
what more can be done not just to
address this current crisis but longer
term to put mitigation measures so in
place so climate change doesn't have
such a drastic impact on those
communities
well my honorable friend is absolutely
right and we discuss uh resilience and
climate adaptation frequently with the
Kenyan government I was there in
December my right honorable friend the
foreign secretary was also there and
spoke to president uh Ruto she may rest
assured that our relationship with Kenya
which is extremely uh close and dwells
on humanitarian trade and investment
issues also dwells on the issues of uh
drought and the issues that she has
raised
I'm grateful Mr Speaker across East
Africa 48 million people are facing
crisis level of hunger and yet East
Africa has been taken out of the
integrated review even his own
colleagues understand that the
fundamental issues in East Africa is
about climate adaptation and real
partnership what is the government going
to do to address the fundamental causes
that causes a cycle of these crises
well The Honorable lady is is is is
wrong about it being taken out of the IR
um and if she has the chance this
weekend to study it in detail she will
see that that is the case and she's
right to say that an estimated 72
million people will require humanitarian
assistance in 2023 due to conflict
drought and flooding on all of those
issues Britain is working with its
allies across the International
Community to have to do everything we
can to stop it uh recognizing that this
is the fifth consecutive season of
failed Reigns across the Horn of Africa
name down a Johnson number four Mr
Speaker
Mr Speaker the simple principle is that
Russia should pay for the harm and the
Damage that it has caused and we must
ensure that any proposals are robust
safe and compliant with domestic and
international law we will of course
consider all lawful routes to ensure
that Russia pays for the damage and harm
it has caused
Liam Daniel Johnson can I thank me for
un secretary and although the UK
government has frozen Russian assets the
EU has already set out a plan to ship
these assets into a fund to help rebuild
Ukraine and Canada has already passed a
law to do the same so what's stopping us
why can't we do the same here
all right Mr Speaker both those projects
are still in train not neither of them
have come to a conclusion no country has
liquidated frozen assets and as I say
anything that we do needs to be in
complete compliance with both domestic
and international law
speaker reconstruction of Ukraine will
also require rehabilitating and helping
uh women and so can I ask on the wake of
what we've done on preventing sexual
violence and conflict what steps we're
going to be able to take and how we can
help those who have been victims of
sexual violence
I pay tribute to my honorable friend for
the work that he's done in this area for
many many many years I'm very proud of
the fact that the UK has been the
Forefront of campaigns preventing sexual
uh violence and conflict of my Noble
friend the Lord Ahmed organized the
conference last year on this very issue
we must ensure that those perpetrators
the facilitators and those ordering this
brutality are all held to account and
we'll work with International Partners
to ensure that happens
thank you Mr Speaker
um Ukraine's 2023 budget alone has a 38
billion dollar Gap and the Damage Done
to critical infrastructure runs into the
hundreds of billions there is one party
responsible Russia now we support the
government's plans for a reconstruction
conference this summer but we therefore
cannot have any dragging of the heels in
making Russia foot the bill for its
barbarous War so we've heard the other
International examples when will the
foreign secretary set out a clear plan
to seize not just freeze Russian State
assets and repurpose them yeah
Mr Speaker the sad but simple truth is
it is not as easy as his question
implies the fact is there have been
conflicts around the world before there
have been perpetrators before there has
never been a seizure of assets and as I
say we need to make sure we need to make
sure that we are compliant with both
domestic and international law we will
look carefully at the proposals which
are currently being explored and tested
by our close close friends and allies on
this but I can reassure him and the
house
that we will ensure working in close
cooperation with our friends
internationally that Russia pays for the
brutality that we are seeing in Ukraine
Mr Speaker
UK Aid ranging from search and rescue to
tents to Medical Care has helped
thousands of survivors in turkey and
Syria over 9 000 patients have been
treated by UK Medical Teams as of the
7th of March
but lastly I was honored to speak with
members of the British Turkish community
and learn about the ongoing Aid efforts
to help those impacted by a disaster I
was also fortunate to visit gazaniantep
in 2019 with our late friends of David
Amos meeting with families displaced by
the war in Syria so it's heartbreaking
to see so many of these people once
again find themselves having to rebuild
their lives with my right honorable
friend commit to ensuring that this
government's efforts will go beyond just
initial disaster relief providing
long-term support for those in the
region to rebuild their lives their
homes and their businesses
well as my audible friend will will know
Britain for the for the overall Syria
crisis Britain has contributed since it
began something like 3.8 billion pounds
which is more than the whole of the rest
of the European Union uh added together
so we will certainly focus on that for
for now the British taxpayer has found
43 million pounds the the dec has raised
100 million pounds all across the
country people are magnificently
responding to this crisis and I know
that in my own constituency of Sutton
coalfield on Saturday night there is a
concert at Columbus church where the
Sutton coalfield chamber choir will be
will be playing in order to raise money
for Turkish victims Jim Shannon Mr
Speaker more than 850 000 children
remain displaced after the earthquakes
had hit in early February with many of
these children now in temporary shelters
what discussions have had with turkey
subtitles to ensure that all is done to
return children to a person see if they
locate their families and also to
educate them thank you
well he he's right on all counts Mr
Speaker and of course uh immediately
after the crisis education cannot wait
allocated seven million dollars to try
and make sure that children particularly
who are out of school could get back
into education and we will continue to
ensure that those efforts for people who
have suffered so much from the
earthquake are remedied in every way
that we can
Greg Smith number six sir
Mr Speaker the UK will continue to hold
the Iranian regime including the irgc to
account for its repression we have
imposed sanctions upon those individuals
who have been involved in the repression
of women in Iran and we continue to
sanction the irgc in its entirety
Mark okay just two questions
Greg Smith
thank you Mr Speaker I'm grateful to my
writable friend for that answer
but the evidence of the irgc's brutality
in Iran particularly towards women is
clear
the evidence of their wider malign
influence in the region
is clear
likewise there are links to supporting
Russia and their reach to Europe
including threats on these our own
Shores
so how much more evidence does my right
honorable friend and the government need
to see before the government does what
I've asked many many times in this
chamber to do and prescribe the irgc
as I say the irgc has already sanctioned
in its entirety where it is involved
with illegal activity our security
forces and police forces take actions
and I commend the actions that they take
we don't routinely discuss future
designations and sanctions but we will
always take actions which protect
British people British interests and
deter them align Activity
thank you Mr Speaker like like the
foreign secretary's honorable friend I
come to this chamber again and again and
again and ask about prescribing the irgc
they're widely recognized on both sides
of the house as a bunch of clerical
fascists and homicidal Maniacs who
particularly enjoy torturing and
murdering women I suspect the foreign
secretary agrees with us as on both
sides of the house why didn't they make
that final step and just prescribe them
Mr Speaker the actions this government
take with regard to the rgc are to deter
their malign activity both within their
own borders within the region and here
in the UK to protect uh British citizens
including dual Nationals and British
interests overseas we will always act in
accordance with those principles and as
I say the UK government does not
routinely uh speculate about future
designations Butler
question eight
this decision is disappointing for the
Falkland Islands for the UK and for
Argentina there are many areas in which
our countries tend to gain through
working together positively including
the humanitarian effort with uh to
identify Fallen Argentine service
Personnel from the 1982 conflict The
Joint communique covers all of these
areas and more the Argentine
government's decision hurts our mutually
beneficial bilateral cooperation it
further damages the Falkland Islands
Islanders confidence its intentions and
that's why Argentina should reconsider
its decision we're working closely with
the Falkland Islanders to identify next
steps
I was lucky enough to visit the Falkland
Islands a few weeks ago with the Armed
Forces parliamentary scheme and meeting
local people there it was absolutely
clear that they powerfully and
passionately stand by the referendum
result of exactly 10 years ago when more
than 90 voted for the Falklands to
remain a British overseas territory this
makes Argentina's recent unilateral
decision to abandon the joint communique
all the more outrageous so can my ride
on my friend tell this house what the
government is doing to make clear to the
argentinians that the Falkland Islanders
have the unequivocal right to
self-determination and how the UK will
protect that in practice
uh Mr Speaker it would be remiss of me
not to welcome the 10th anniversary of
the referendum on the future of the
Falcon Islands it is only the people of
the Falkland Islands to decide their own
future we consistently make clear to
Argentina and to the international
Partners our unbending support for the
Falkland Islanders and for their
self-determination rights
the Falklands are British and that's the
end of the story
and Santiago kafiro is undoubtedly
engaging a little bit of electioneering
during general election and we should
just kind of exactly as the foreign
secretary just said we shouldn't be
surprised when these things are said can
I ask however many of my constituents uh
lost loved ones who were killed on the
Galahad
um in the defense of the Falklands many
years ago some of them are worried that
there are some papers that have been not
published yet and won't be published
until 2065 they would like to see the
full papers that weren't provided that
were provided to the board of inquiry
will he investigate whether those can
now be published
I think the honorable member of making
those points in these original remarks
as well there are usual processes to go
through but I'll take those points away
and discuss them with the minister of
overseas territories
contain Mr Speaker
we're concerned by recent wide-ranging
arrests in Tunisia including politicians
former civil servants business people
and media Representatives the UK
underlines the importance of due legal
process and respect for human rights
especially freedoms of expression and
association tunisians should have the
space for legitimate political
opposition as well as civil society and
Independent Media activity
is seeking to impose one-man rule in
Tunisia including with hashan parliament
in the arrest of critics and now appears
to be looking for scapegoats such as
black Africans to distract attention
from the dire economic and social
situation will the minister condemn what
is happening now in Tunisia and support
those working for Democratic intolerant
governance in the country
the minister for North Africa publicly
commented on this on the 16th of
February he's also raised the issue of
the Tunisian childhood Affairs and the
G7 ambassadors in Tunis have also made a
number of joint statements since June
July 2021 we're aware also of reports of
racially motivated discrimination and
violence towards perceived sub-Saharan
African migrants and we encourage
Tunisia to comply with the International
Convention on the elimination of all
forms of racial discrimination
Mr Speaker we welcome the independent
review by the bishop Arturo and ensure
it is Central to our human rights work
the other Bros
almost a year after the expert
independent review which highlighted
there is still much work to be done to
fully implement the true review can the
minister point out what progress the
fcdo has made in better advocating for
those who have persecuted for their
religion or belief and not least can the
minister confirm that as our Manifesto
promised and in accordance with
recommendations six of Truro that the
role of the PM's special embryon Ford
will now be established in law
well Mr Speaker I want to thank my
honorable friend for all her work and
commitment in this vehicle area and and
who can doubt that my honorable friend
like our honorable friend for Jillian
and Raynham before her is the very
personification the essence of how this
role should be performed last July we
had an International Ministerial
conference to advance freedom of
religion and belief and we always
regularly raise cases of concern and in
respect of article 6 can I say to her
that she makes an extremely good point
and the government is considering it
question 13 Mr Speaker
[Applause]
Mr Speaker we are working with a range
of jurisdictions including G20 Nations
and Global Financial Centers to promote
beneficial ownership transparency and to
make it a global Norm
Penrose right old friend has a superb
personal track record on the tissue and
can I urge him to redouble his efforts
would he accept that transparency about
who owns what means that oligarchs
kleptocrats and climate crime Lords have
fewer places to stash their dirty cash
and is the single cheapest and most
effective measure any country can take
to cut the social and economic costs
that International criminality imposes
would he further accept that it becomes
ever more powerful as the network of
truly transparent business growth
well Mr Speaker open registers of
beneficial ownership are extremely
important and he and I and indeed the
right honorable lady for barking did a
lot of work on that from the back
benches and that is now a government
policy
um Mr Speaker all overseas territories
and Crown dependencies are committed to
this open uh registers all have made
voluntary commitments and the government
intends to ensure that they stand by
those commitments foreign
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I was in
Cox's Bazaar just on Saturday and I was
able to visit for myself the site of
this terrible fire where 12 000 people
were affected and 2 000 homes were
destroyed
um I was able to announce a new package
of funding 5.26 million uh to support
the rohingya and I was able to meet the
agencies who are all working at
incredible place to help them rebuild
their homes Russian I thank the minister
for her answer and for paying that
important visit she will be aware the UN
food program announced that it's been
forced to reduce rations to rohingya
refugees by 17
because of wider funding cuts and
despite the recent announcements she's
made since uh 2020 the UK Aid budget to
the rohingya refugee crisis gone down by
about just over 80 percent how can that
be justifiable for a population that's
faced genocide at the hands of the
Burmese military and has she had
discussions with the chancellor about
restoring the overall Aid budget for
that is the best way to ensure we tackle
Refugee crisis
Mr Speaker the UK has been a leading
donor to the rohingya crisis providing
over 350 million pounds since 2017. uh
last week at the UN The Joint response
plan was published which is only so far
just over 40 funded so we will be
working with our friends across the
world to find the funding to support
that completely
number 18.
Mr Speaker I have the pleasure of
meeting all the front runner candidates
ahead of the election and officials have
continued engagement with a range of
counterparts throughout
thank you Mr Speaker the UK has a
vibrant and engaged Nigerian diaspora I
know I count myself as one of them now
Indie Igbo Northeast England in my
consistency of expressed concerns it's
serious failures of Technology security
and Communications in last month's
presidential elections as has the
European Union given that the government
have provided financial support to
Nigerian civil society and electric
integrity and Technical advice to the
Nigerian independent National electoral
commission what does the minister think
went wrong
well I'm a speaker she's entirely right
that we provided five million pounds of
taxpayers money to Civil Society to
boost citizen education and voter
engagement and the British High
commission deployed observers to polling
stations across seven states uh we
commend all those involved for their
commitment to democracy and also
importantly in respect of our question
to resolving disputes through the courts
and through peaceful means administer
Limbaugh
I'm enormously grateful Mr Speaker
Nigeria is a fast-growing commute
country and connections between our
communities are flourishing so if
Nigerians lose trust in their political
institutions it will affect our
prosperity and security too but the
government's development support for
Nigeria has been slashed our offer is
lacking and our voice is weak surely we
need a to develop a strategy for
partnership in Nigeria and across the
whole of Africa how's the minister going
to deliver on this
well we are working incredibly closely
with all our partners across Africa uh
none more so than Nigeria we've been
very heavily engaged in the recent
events we note that the gubernatorial
elections have been rescheduled to the
18th of March but the government has
congratulated president-elect to nubu we
look forward to welcoming working with
his administration and dealing with
exactly the matters that The Honorable
lady has so eloquently raised come to
topicals but because
speaker on behalf of the people of
Stockton South at one
secretary
thank you
uh Mr Speaker yesterday I set out how
the government will ensure the country
remains safe prosperous and influential
in San Diego yesterday afternoon the
Prime Minister alongside President Biden
the Prime Minister Albanese announced
how we will deliver a multi-billion
pound conventional armed but
nuclear-powered submarine capabilities
to roll Australian Navy last month we
negotiated Windsor framework for
Northern Ireland with our European Union
colleagues and last week the UK French
Summit we struck a deal that will help
stop the boats from bringing illegal
migrants to the UK the on Ukraine UK
stands ready to provide a further 500
million dollars of world bank loan
guarantees to cover the cost of vital
government services we're accelerating
the delivery of a 2.3 billion pounds
worth of military aid and Challenger
tanks and we'll keep so speaker on
behalf of the people of Stockton South I
would like to offer our deepest
condolences to the families of victims
of last month's devastating Turkish
Syrian earthquake I was glad to see the
government's Fast Response in sending
humanitarian aid but can my right on the
bull friend and sure the UK will assist
both Syria and turkey in elaborating
strategies to prevent any future natural
disaster I'm such a devastating High
fatality rate Mr Speaker I pay tribute
to my right honorable friend the
development Minister who traveled to the
region shortly after the earthquakes
keeping a close eye on the Swift
response that we deployed both financial
and Technical I can assure him and the
house that we will continue to pay close
attention to the humanitarian need as a
great result of these series of
earthquakes in turkey and Syria
thank you very much Mr Speaker in recent
weeks allies in the US and the EU have
moved to ban Tick-Tock from government
phones but UK government ministers
response is it's a personal choice will
the foreign secretary clarify if the
government will recommend a government
agency ban or will the UK be behind the
curve again
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an issue which is because it's a
security matter is taken up by the
security minister which is a home office
competency
all right okay sorry
um last week the UK warned that the
regime in Tehran is now dangerously
close to actual weapons related
activities after Iran was caught
enriching uranium to 83.7 by the iaea
considering Iran has systematically
escalated its nuclear activities in the
face of diplomatic efforts does my right
humble friend agree with me the time has
now come for a snapback and sanctions as
inscribed in the jcpla
uh we continue to work closely with our
International partners and with the
leadership of the IE iaea on Iran's
nuclear activities uh our position is
clear it is unacceptable for Iran to
acquire a nuclear weapon or nuclear
weapon technology we will continue to
work with our International allies to
prevent that from happening thank you um
I'd refer to my entry in register
entrance chair at the all party group on
Aid match uh the government funding
rounds of UK match and Gabby and malaria
match he ended in 2023 totaling 377
million pounds over 377 million pounds
represents just three point percent of
you 3.7 0.3 sorry of UK odor uh when
will the next round of Aid match be
announced how much will it be announced
and will the government increase the
percentage of odor that is Aid matched
well Mr Speaker he's quite right to
accentuate the importance of Aid match
it's done an enormous amount to swell
the amount of funds that can be deployed
um I will come back to the house as soon
as we are able to set out the amounts
that we will be spending in the next
financial Year and I hope in the
financial year thereafter as well
some striking parallels between the 2022
invasion of Ukraine by Russia and the
1974 invasion of Cyprus by turkey
both involved aggressive incursions into
the Sovereign territory of another
country so will the foreign secretary
call on Turkey to remove its troops from
Cyprus and enable cypriots to determine
their own future
well thank you Mr Speaker of course the
UK led the international response to
Turkish access the 974 including through
drafting unhcr 353 calling resolution
353 calling for the immediate withdrawal
of Turkish troops and of course the best
way to address the situation in Cyprus
is to through a just and Lasting
settlement in line with un parameters
based on the model of a bison or by
communal Federation and the UK Mr
Speaker will continue to actively engage
in pursuit of this yeah Patrick ready
come here on small boats or fleeing War
where this country has sold the weapons
natural disasters where this government
has given up on tackling climate change
and hunger and disease for this
government slashed the aid budget how
does anything in yesterday's integrated
review tackle the push factors that
cause so much displacement and migration
in the first place
foreign
review published yesterday sets out a
comprehensive approach to dealing with
all these issues including particularly
migration and migration is a complex
area which requires a whole series of
different interventions there is a last
no Silver Bullet
and Jack Robertson
speaker the behavior of Iran is
increasingly concerning as my honorable
friend for Buckingham said earlier the
particular behavior of the irgc is
particularly concerning so what will my
writing will friend be doing more to
tackle this threat and particularly be
working with our allies to make sure we
take this attack this threat head on
Mr Speaker we have sanctioned both
individuals and entities in response to
their malign Behavior including the
sanctioning of the irgc in its entirety
will continue to work very very closely
with our International allies and
friends in the region to deter Iran and
the irgc from further such actions
like stories of horrific war crimes
being used against Russian forces by
Russian forces against the Ukraine
people including sexual crimes and rapes
against children as young as poor and
women as old as 90. so what is the
government doing to ensure a special
Tribunal for the crime of aggression is
going to be set up
we continue to work with the ICC in
terms of ensuring that they are able to
bring people to Justice we are working
closely with our friends internationally
to look at what other legal Vehicles we
may need to ensure that whether they be
perpetrators facilitators or right up to
the decision makers in Moscow itself
everybody is held to account for the
brutality and the perverse actions that
are taking place by Russian troops in
Ukraine so bottom layer the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia
I have to give you assurances they
wouldn't be carrying out death penalties
just executed for saying Abu al-qia
father of eight
will the foreign secretary try to
arrange later this week to make a
statement to the house on the
ramifications on our relationships with
Saudi Arabia recognizing there are
people like the 14 year old Abdullah
al-hawiti who was tortured to make a
confession for a crime he couldn't have
committed
the UK strongly opposes the death
penalty in all countries and
circumstances we regularly raise our
concerns with the Saudi authorities
Saudi Arabia is well aware of the UK's
opposition to the death penalty
Let's Twist thank you Mr Speaker and
following on from the father of the
house uh on Sunday Hussein Avo alkia was
executed in Saudi Arabia despite
allegations he'd been severely tortured
and despite calls from the uni
commissioner to halt his execution and
last year the number of people executed
in Saudi Arabia reached a record high
with 81 people killed in a single day so
come the minister explained further how
the UK is working with our International
allies
as I said we we strongly oppose the
death penalty in all countries and
circumstances and as far as the alkia
situation Lord Ahmed raised the case
with the Saudi Ambassador with the Saudi
Vice foreign minister and the president
of the Saudi Human Rights Commission on
multiple occasions since November and
including his visit to the kingdom in
February
the abduction so-called re-education and
illegal adoption 6000 Ukrainian children
is an act of genocide so far the UK has
only sanctioned two Russian Governors
complicit in this activity which clearly
has been learned from China and Tibetan
xinjiang so will we now back avas's
campaign and sanction the further eight
individuals responsible for this
including those directors of so-called
boarding houses for Ukrainian children
Mr Speaker the uh abduction uh forcible
deportation and Tall intense purposes
kidnap of Ukrainian children is a a
terrible and perverse act I can assure
uh my honorable friend and the house
that we will not rest until the people
who are involved in this are held to
account she will know that we do not
routinely uh discuss future
um uh sanctions designations but I can
assure her we look very very closely
with our International Partners at this
terrible terrible State of Affairs
a loophole in the sanctions regime means
that Russian steel is rolled in
countries like turkey and then imported
to the UK the foreign secretary will
know that the that steel production in
the UK is the is the only we are the
only country in the G20 it's declining
and our domestic steel production is of
course essential for our support for
Ukraine
so will he follow the lead of the EU
which is closing the loophole on this
practice and tell us when the UK will
also close the loophole
it was a lively uh debate on this in the
Westminster Hall last week and I can
confirm that obviously our sanctions
regimes are under constant review on our
enforcement activity uh with hmrc in
particular will be focused on these
issues policy in least developed
countries
um over half of Health Centers don't
have hand washing facilities and I
recently saw the benefits of delivering
these during a trip to Ghana with the
charity waste Aid the government's new
health position papers contain
approaches to integrate Water Sanitation
hygiene with health programming so will
the minister commit to progress these
implementation of these to raise
standards of hygiene and reduce levels
of infection across the developing world
yes Mr Speaker
Jill furnace
thank you Mr Speaker the crisis in
Kashmir announced funds across nine
decades and today those living in the
region still face unimaginable human
rights abuses police brutality arbitrary
arrests and repression of journalists
there are still too common will the
minister ensure that the plights of the
kashmiris is not forgotten and
furthermore will he launch A Renewed
effort to facilitate dialogue between
Pakistan and India so there's a
political solution can be found
yeah
Mr Speaker the UK's long-standing
position is as it is for India and
Pakistan to find a lasting political
resolution on Kashmir taking into
account the wishes of kashmiri people
and we continue to monitor the situation
and encourage both countries to engage
in dialogue and to find those lasting
diplomatic solutions to maintain
Regional stability
Henry Anthony Higginbotham
the Ukrainian economy is suffering
immeasurably because of the war imposed
by Russia
but one of the things that would help
the Ukrainian economy now unpost
conflict is more joint ventures with
Western multinationals which helps not
just with economic growth but with
governance reforms as well so could ask
what steps we're taking to help those
Ukrainian companies partner with Western
multinationals
uh Mr Speaker my honorable friend mates
absolutely the right Point as well as
ensuring that the Russians that are
violated Ukraine uh
repair the damage that they have caused
of course there will be a need for a
long-term relationship to build rebuild
the Ukrainian economy UK export finance
will help british-based companies help
ukrainians rebuild their Homeland once
we have helped them successfully defend
themselves against this Invasion my name
is Mr Speaker for the past 15 months I
and my team have been battling to bring
five British children who are in hiding
in Kabul to safety their British father
was blown up by the Taliban their Afghan
mother won't be granted a Visa by the
home office and they're too young to
travel alone neither the foreign office
nor the home office are responding to my
correspondence on this case please will
the Secretary of State or one of the
ministers please grant me an Urgent
meeting so that we can bring this family
to safety
I will look into the point that she's
made about her correspondence not being
responded to
um and I will and I will
yeah
oh look into the point she's made about
her correspondence not being respond
being responded to and will of course
take the opportunity to meet with her to
find out the situation as you know we do
not have a consular presence in
Afghanistan itself but our Consular
teams in neighboring countries
our Consular team in neighboring
countries do of course provide remote
support for British Nationals overseas
Henry Smith thank you Mr Speaker earlier
on in this session we heard about the
importance of respecting
self-determination as for the case of
the future of the Falkland Islands can I
write honorable friend update the house
with regard to consultations with the
chagossian people on the future of the
British Indian Ocean territory
uh my uh right honorable friend uh Lord
Goldsmith from The Other Place had a
meeting with representatives of the
chigosian uh Community uh we will of
course uh ensure that as far as we can
we keep uh those lines of communications
open
Mr Speaker on the 25th of January
in an urgent question on whether the
government had assisted the bargaining
group in circum circumventing UK
sanctions I asked the minister how many
exceptions do and waivers to the rules
there have been over the last two years
the minister said a letter would be sent
to be it is now the 14th of March better
said on the 25th of January will the
foreign secretary ensure that that
letter is sent to me
uh thank you for bringing that to my
attention I will ensure that I find out
why there's been such a protracted delay
and ensure that he gets response in good
time
so Jeremy Wright
whether China is a threat a challenge an
opportunity or all of the above the UK's
response to it will surely be enhanced
by better Chinese language skills can my
right honorable friend assure me that
he's doing what he can with colleagues
in government to improve the UK's
capacity in this regard
Mr Speaker and the interest rate review
published yesterday we have set out a
comprehensive list of tools that we'll
be bringing to help us continue and grow
our Mandarin speakers and more widely
and I recommend all members of the house
to have a full summary of it in due
course
ear cap is the largest provider of
commercial aircraft in the world and
after the imposition of sanctions they
required a number of least aircraft in
Russia to be returned that hasn't
happened and the aircraft have instead
re-registered in Russia and continued to
fly and operate now I know there's a
court case on the issue of loss with the
insurance industry but does the
government consider this to be an
example of sanctions division
I would speak it was very difficult for
me to come to an assessment base just on
the points made in the question I'm more
than happy to look at this in more
detail if you're right to me about this
or or catch me uh privately as I say
with regard to the legal action he will
understand of course government can't
comment whilst that is ongoing
thank you speaker I recently visited the
occupied Palestinian territories and
what I saw made a deep and Lasting
Impression on me will the minister agree
with me and with former Israeli
Ambassador Ilan Baruch who I met with
yesterday that the UK and others must
stop giving Israel impunity for its
illegal actions under international law
and once again becomes serious and
active players for peace
I just saw the honorable lady that we
want nothing more than peace in this
region I have met I have visited the
apts I've met with representatives of
the Palestinian Authority and I met with
Israelis and of course it is in
everybody's interest that we have peace
in the region both for Israelis and
Palestinians and for the wider region
and that will continue to be at the
heart of the UK foreign policy in the
region
thank you Mr Speaker I'm grateful for
the many pieces of Correspondence I've
had from the foreign office regarding
the death of my constituent son abroad
many parliamentary creations and binary
interactions across this chamber can I
ask the foreign secretary if he would
meet with me to discuss the finer points
that will allow my constituent closure
in this case
Mr Speaker I know um The Honorable
gentleman has been a great champion and
advocate for his constituent and that
officials have continued to get informed
and I will be happy to meet with him uh
to discuss that more fully if he wishes
thank you British Nationals and mechron
Road still remain incarcerated in Iran
what's the foreign secretary going to do
to bring them home
uh I can assure the uh honorable lady
that we continue to make every effort to
support British dual Nationals in Iran
uh both an incarceration this remains an
ongoing piece of work and she will
understand that it is not always
possible for us to it's not always
possible for us to go into details it's
not always in the best interest of the
individuals for us to go into details
but I can assure her this remains a
priority for the UK and one of the
reasons why it's important that we
maintain a bilateral diplomatic
relationship with Iran
Mr Speaker the foreign secretary should
be well aware of the huge demonstrations
in Israel opposing the government's
plans to control the Judiciary which
will undermine the rule of law a
situation described by the president of
Israel yesterday is very serious does he
share president herzog's concerns
I mean ultimately of course the
government of Israel needs to understand
is has a responsibility to the people of
Israel we always suggest that uh when uh
when there are protests that governments
listen to why those protests are
happening and of course we want to see
Israel abide by uh the rule of law I
can't live forward thank you
the Russell group has coordinated new
research highlighting the the scale of
the ongoing delays in the eight in eight
hours and which is having a detrimental
impact on students research projects and
universities and these delays have
already led to businesses retract and
funding and PhD applicants withdrawn
from UK opportunities will the minister
what discussions has a minister had with
these cabinet colleagues about this and
will he meet with me to discuss the
findings of the Russell group yeah
we recognize that International students
coming to UK universities is an
incredibly important uh uh part of our
economy it's important for our soft
power internationally and of course it's
one of those things where the knowledge
that those students take back to their
countries of origin helps those
countries as well we recognize how
important it is and we will continue to
I will continue to work with other
government departments to ensure our
International students remains top
quality remember thank you Mr Speaker
the global crisis of malnutrition now
threatens the lives of 200 million
people and so will the development
secretary look to support my early day
motion 951 that seeks to welcome the
bridge down agenda that will transform
the mission the model and the money in
the global Finance development
architecture because now is not the time
for half measures
Mr Speaker the right honorable gentleman
be aware that government ministers don't
normally sign early day motions but in
respect to his point about Bridgetown
there is no more important agenda around
internationally we need to ensure that
we turn billions into trillions as the
rich world has promised repeatedly at
recent cops and the Bridgetown agenda is
in very large part the way you do that
much Mr Speaker I was honored to attend
the UN Commission on the status of women
last week and hurt in the world
Association of Girl Guides and girls
Scopes about their she serfs Freedom
surfy which highlighted the impact
online harassment misogyny and abuse is
having on girls around the world so can
I ask what actions he intends to take to
work with Partners to ensure a free and
equal digital future yeah
well she's making a very good point and
I will study the results of those events
if she will make them available to me
then the government will consider what
in addition to what it's doing already
it may be able to do
that completes the questions